la décision critique que nous avons prise au début
était l'animation sur les diablos,
nous voulions vous montrer certains des plans
afin que vous puissiez voir ce que vous avez vu à Tokyo
et puis ce que nous avons changé, cela semble
très très proche du jeu,
donc nous avons  une comparaison,
les rathalos du film et les
ratholos du jeu
viennent avec le pacte d'améliorations que vous
avez fait quelque chose qu'il n'a pas pu
faire dans le développement du jeu, donc il est
vraiment heureux de voir cela
et vous avez incorporé tellement de choses qui
nous avons discuté donc il est vraiment
reconnaissant, vraiment impressionné si nous pouvons
livrer pour vous
nous pouvons livrer pour les fans
qu'est-ce que c'est que sur nos six qu'est-ce que c'est que
sur nos six [ __ ] de merde
toi